hi good morning first of all I want to
say that I'm very happy to be here in
Sydney it's my first time in Australia
I'm from the USA and I came here to talk
a little bit about one of my passions
which is view Jas so I first looked at
view Jas a few years ago and I had
already been through a lot of different
JavaScript tooling and frameworks and
had what they call JavaScript fatigue at
that time so I didn't pursue it I had
done quite a bit of consulting work for
a backbone react angular among other
things and so I wasn't overly
enthusiastic when I first saw it and
then I started hearing that view Jas was
the new jQuery that it was so usable so
easy to teach and because I also teach
JavaScript I've had a lot of pains and
trying to explain various concepts and
state management and things to people
who are newer in development so I
decided to take a stab at it again and I
realized even though I was already
content with react and had been using it
for a while that view Jas is also a good
framework it uses a lot of the same good
ideas the virtual Dom but it's much
simpler and easier to use and teach and
so today I aim to explore why the view
J's framework or why I have chosen UJ s
above other frameworks and tools and
also perhaps you will agree with some of
my points that I make but in any case I
hope to convey why it's the fastest
growing JavaScript framework of all time
and why there's so much hype over it so
my name is Gwen I'm from the US I live
in the Midwest right now and I am very
passionate about developer education I
think that's one of the biggest
inequalities in Western society and
perhaps in the world is access to
education so right now I work with a
start-up called crossroads where we hire
people to teach them and let them learn
while they're being paid and then they
can grow with us I've also been part of
free code camp community for over three
years writing articles contributing
mentoring it's a really phenomenal
community for coders of all levels and I
run a local group in the USA to help
teach people support people and
encourage people as they learn to code
because it's not easy for people of any
level so the itinerary for what I want
to talk about today is since it's a
newer framework and especially the stats
show in Australia it's a bit
underrepresented here and react is way
over represented so I'm gonna go over
some of the basic syntax and how it's
used but not get too much into that
and it's not really going to be an
advanced talk it's more of a 10,000 foot
overview of the ecosystem and how things
work so what is VJ s I think it's
important to understand some of the
history behind view and you can then
understand the goals and use cases of
the framework so it was created in 2013
or it was launched in 2013 but it's
created by a former Google engineer
called named Evan you he had previously
worked heavily with angular on the
Google teams and he was part of a
creative labs team that had to spin up
new interesting solutions and projects
all the time so he was really looking
for something that was easy to use in
the front-end for rapid prototyping and
he couldn't find anything that was
lightweight could be incrementally
adoptable and was easy enough to use so
he kind of took the best things from a
lot of other frameworks from angular and
react which had just come out recently
at the time and Facebook had been
working on it for a few years internally
though and the ease of use of jQuery and
combine them all into one framework and
you might think it's gonna be a mess
just having so many things in one
framework but he actually took a lot of
good ideas because a lot of frameworks
had
good ideas and that's why they were
adopted so view is kind of combined all
of these good ideas combined with
ease-of-use and good documentation and
that's why it's spreading so fast right
now so some of the main features of UJS
is that it offers simple syntax to use
more complicated functionality it
borrowed or it stole really directives
from angular directive is like a special
markup token that links something in
your JavaScript to a Dom element but in
view the concept of a directive is much
much simpler than its implementation and
angular and it also uses to a data
binding so you can either use it as a
directive in your HTML using V bind
which will bind and update the Dom
whenever that data updates or you can
use a knockout like syntax with double
curly braces and it will parse anything
inside double curly braces as JavaScript
and then render it to the Dom the
concept of view is similar to react it's
a lot of modular components if you've
used react before I think it's probably
much more common to have react
experience so react you're basically
taking all these files which are
components and you're rendering your
HTML or your view from your JavaScript
so view is very similar in where it's
broken up by file into component and at
the top of the file you have your HTML
template and then which is just a
standard html5 syntax there's no nothing
new made by view here they're using a
lot of common web standards which makes
it really nice and simple for new people
coming into the framework as well
then you have your script tag below in
the same file which anything inside of
course is parsed as JavaScript and that
will be your data and methods and
everything associated with your view or
with your JavaScript and then you can
also put your styling in your same file
you can either scope it or just have it
in the related styling in the same file
and then it will be compiled all into
one stylesheet if you want it's very
flexible you can choose to use instead
of HTML you could use JavaScript or you
could use pug or even JSX if you wanted
to it has built-in support for
typescript and for forge of your styles
it's very easy to just say I want to
lang equals SAS or lang equals less or
whatever kind of meta language you want
to work so it's a very simple
implementation using a lot of web
standards that are already out there
which also makes it a much lighter
weight framework and easier for people
to adopt and when you look at these web
standards from HTML CSS and JavaScript
they've been you know heavily researched
and built up over the years so if you
didn't want to reinvent a lot of things
that wanted to kind of use what was
already out there and just implement it
into a nice framework style where it
would have a clean syntax and you could
build all of your components in a
standard way and just like other
frameworks out there now it basically
takes all of your components that have
HTML CSS and JavaScript and puts them
into one file and then it will render it
to your Dom so you'll basically you
create a new view instance object and
the L there stands for element which is
the Dom element that your view instance
will be attached to so it's that any
it's the element with the ID of app and
then you basically render your parent
component from your tree of components
into that Dom element pretty standard
so and you'll have the HTML file that
has the idea of app and you link your
bundle j/s so what's special about view
first of all not everyone realizes this
I think coming into programming but
frameworks and tools and all these
abstractions that we use they are
actually made for people not for
machines so the number one thing that I
think sets view apart from every other
framework and tool out there is that it
it's number one focus is on the
developers and designers who are going
to be using the framework and this can
be seen across all areas of view if you
look at what the the statements made by
the core team to the naming conventions
of the framework the tooling the code
style the documentation everything is
built around this concept of
accessibility not over engineering for
really smart people which makes it a
really nice user experience for people
of all levels so I want to go over some
of the ways that they make it kind of
easier to use it's super legible
declarative framework and as a
consultant for a while now I find view
is way easier to jump into a code base
because of the naming and conventions
and styles and everything and sometimes
with other frameworks I've had huge
headache just wondering especially older
frameworks wondering what was going on
when I jumped in there so I think view
brings a lot to the table in terms of
ease of use and implementation it's also
self documenting in a way because it is
so legible which is really nice and you
don't have to clutter up your code with
comments because you can just kind of
read it and understand what it's doing
and it feels like it abstract away a lot
of the things that you feel like you've
done a million times and you but you can
also customize it as much as you want to
because you're right there almost at the
level of the underlying
javascript and HTML and everything so
let's look at starting a view app so
just like most frameworks in JavaScript
you can start by including it the
easiest way to include it in the CDN and
you can kind of drop it into any project
which makes it maybe the most
modular adoptable framework out there or
one of them and then like I showed
earlier you have an element with an ID
where you're going to render your view
instance and your view instance you'll
create this new view object basically as
your review instance and you'll pass it
options the first option that has to be
passed is which Dom element to render or
where to render your view instance and
then it has something called the data
object so the data anything any property
in the data object will be linked can be
linked into your Dom directly by putting
it in the curly braces or by binding it
to your Dom with a directive and you can
just call it by its name and view under
the hood understands that hey you want
something from the data object in your
Dom and then the Dom will update
whenever whenever you change something
in the view yeah so you can also bind
things with a directive which i think is
super legible how they built their
directives in view and they also have a
lot of easy shortcuts so if instead of
writing out the bind : source you can
just write out : source and any any HTML
attribute you can put a colon before it
and that means it will be controlled by
the view javascript which is also easy
to read
and for inputs it's very easy to do the
two-way data-binding you can just use
the v-model attribute on your inputs and
then in your data declare whatever
variable you want to model it after and
now in the data object name will
automatically update as a user types in
and for events it's also quite easy to
handle events and to link them up to
your JavaScript you can use avión
directive and then all of the H standard
HTML events will be there for you to use
like key up on click mouse over all of
those standard events and there are also
things called modifiers in view so the
dot thirteen the dot enter all of those
are modifiers that you put on to the
event so the enter the enter key has the
key code of 13 where you can just use
the word enter and view knows that hey
when this event happens when the enter
key is pressed then I'll run this
function called submit and you can also
chain
so you could do kiap dot enter dot
prevent now prevent you can probably
tell from reading it is prevent default
so a lot of very common things that
developers do whenever you're writing in
a function that's triggered by an event
you almost always use you know Y dot
prevent default or prevent default you
also use stop propagation so you could
also change stop there and so on and so
on you can change as many things and
it's done in a really clear fashion and
also the shortcut for events because
they're used so frequently instead of V
on colon you can just use at and then
the event name like at kiap which is
also super legible and readable even if
you didn't you hadn't used view before I
think you could figure out what it was
doing there
and so this is just an example of how
the function is run so you have a data
object and you also have a methods
object and so it will look view will
look for things with the name submit
inside of those so it sees as a method
called submit and it will run that
method whenever that event occurs and
this is just an example if you doing you
can do an act click event it will also
run submit and you can access anything
in your data object from your JavaScript
just by doing this dot the name of your
data attribute so you could say this dot
name will grab the name from your data
that's modeled to your user input and
then you can use that in your JavaScript
so it's a very simple way to use the
data and then here are some more
directives which can also be chained so
the if the else if the else it's pretty
obvious what those are doing they're
conditionally rendering the show will
keep something in the Dom but toggle the
display which is much more performant if
you're going to be toggling it a lot
there's also v4 of course that will loop
through arrays and display things so
everything is super readable and life
cycle now this is a very common commonly
used to use case in building SPS today
and just from reading it you can tell
what it's doing you don't have to guess
what the name is it's like jQuery when
we you want to use a function but you
know the API is so big for all these
libraries but you can just say oh I
think it's dot show and it's exactly
what you thought it was but it's the
same with view whenever you're trying to
think of what the function name is then
o created that makes sense
it's not should component update or will
mount or a lot more confusing
terminology used in other libraries and
then of course you can tell from the
tents here that it's something that
happened in the past meaning the
component was already created that it
was already updated it also has pre
event functions so it just changes the
tents and adds up before again super
super legible super easy to understand
what's going on so instead of created
its before create that makes perfect
sense and then there are many other or
many other functions that you can use in
view that help with the speed and with
basically making it more performant as a
hold that they added in so computed
functions this real quick like the
greeting function is actually cached so
it but it's watching the inputs that are
used inside that return statement so
whenever the user updates title or name
it will actually rerun that function and
then cache it which is really nice for
expensive functions that you're not
rerender in it all the time but just
when the when the input updates which I
thought was super cool because it just
if it's it's a computed function it's
automatically watching any of the data
that's used inside that function which
makes something complicated quite easy
to use so animations are also a big part
of you actually recently took a few
animations workshops by Sarah Jasna
she's a member of the core team and she
gave a really good example of how in
real life things don't just appear and
disappear like to get here I had to walk
up on stage and this is what we're used
to
just as
as humans as people so things just
naturally transition so that's a very
important part of UX is to have
transitions so view actually gives a lot
of great built-in transition
functionality and that's just built into
the framework so here you can wrap any
Dom element or a group of elements in a
transition wrapper but the transition
element won't render to the page all
it's doing is creating a kind of a
watcher with name of fade so whenever
whenever it's active it's going to run
these classes so it will run the name of
the transition interactive or the name
of the transition leave active and
there's six different transition classes
that it will automatically run based off
of the state of the transition and she
goes into way more depth than me so if
you're interested in animations she goes
really deep into not only these kind of
animations but also how keyframe
animations can be used in view j/s which
was really awesome because I never
consider myself much of a designer
before but I was able to make some cool
things so learning the basics is all
well and good and unfortunately that's
where a lot of tools and libraries leave
it they'll give you like this hello
world example and then you know go
figure it out for yourself but view I
think does a really good job of helping
you at every stage of development and so
if you're starting out with view of
course the best place to go is the docks
and the docks are actually audited over
and over again by members of the core
team and community for their ease of
user understanding and they said that it
was because they wanted even the newest
developers or people who maybe didn't
speak the language that well that they
could just jump in
understand and it doesn't just cover the
basics by the way it also goes really in
depth on how components work how
animations work about scaling your
review application and so it it has copy
paste ready examples complete API which
is super awesome and also includes
common mistakes to avoid and then after
you kind of graduate from the guide
there's also the cookbook which is a
great addition it's in beta right now
it's been out for a little while and
they have a lot of real-world examples
that they call recipes inside the
cookbook things like how to use graph QL
in your view app how unit testing works
for invalidating and any number of other
things and they opened it up to the
community and they gave kind of a
boilerplate hey here's how you should
make your view recipes for the cookbook
and it should follow this standard this
is how to make it readable and then they
will out review it and kind of help you
with it for quality and consistency
which is really nice from there there
are lots of great workshops put out by
the core team which I thought this was
really amazing they put a lot of work
into you know onboarding people into the
framework so they put out amazing
workshops this is just three of the core
team members and I thought they've put
out some really high-quality material
but there are many others they put out
lots of training content and they also
host live Q&A s and their chat
frequently it's a discord chat room so
the ecosystem is very important and in
view it's very very lively they try to
give you enough tooling so you're not
reinventing any wheels so to speak
the most common part of the ecosystem or
just building any ASPA is probably
routing it's something that you just
can't avoid and I think one of the best
decisions one thing I'm very happy about
with view is that they make routing it's
a separate package but it's controlled
by the core team and the core project so
this allows it to maintain all the same
focuses of the regular view j/s project
and also be reliably included in view
dev tools and the view CLI and in the
official documentation and it still
allows for optional you use and keeping
with the modular design of view so I'm
just going to give an example of how
easy it is to use view router uno if
this is easy to see but you just import
view and you import router and then
whatever components you want to render
in the different routes you use a very
simple syntax to attach it to your view
instances just view use router it's very
easy and then you create a new router
object and you pass it basically a
routes array so your routes array will
be just objects telling it what path you
want your route to have what name you
want your route to have which component
that route is tied to and you can have
as many routes as you want and then you
just import it and import that router
into your main view instance as router
and your router works it's so easy to
use and you there are also lots of other
functionality you can use with the
router some of the most common things
are setting history mode if you want if
you have a server setup and you want to
get rid of that hashtag
slash forward slash syntax and also
scroll behavior in SPS it doesn't always
scroll to the top when you're navigating
routes so you can just set it to scroll
to the top if that's the functionality
that you want
and then for routes you can it gives you
some easy ways to do all of the common
things you're probably going to do
redirects you just pass it a redirect
object until it which route you want it
to redirect to you can also use that for
authentication for if you have child
routes you just pass it an array of
child routes it uses a lot of just
standard JavaScript that you're used to
seeing so it doesn't have a really high
learning curve for any of these tools
the next most common thing and something
I've never worked in a professional app
without is state management so I've used
a ton of Redux and some of angular's
internal state management and some
hacked internal projects and just like
with view router the core team also
maintains view X which is part of the
the official view umbrella and I've had
a lot of headaches teaching new
developers how to use redux they just
did not understand Redux and I've talked
to Dan Abramov online he's a very nice
person but I don't think he put or the
people behind redux put the usability
and onboarding first in their
implementation even though it had some
good ideas behind it
so this is from a tweet I think someone
trying to learn Redux which basically
speaks for itself so view X is trying to
simplify this whole world of state
management and all the craziness so just
like view router you use the view dot
use syntax and you pass it view X say
you want to use view X with this app and
then you create a new view X store
object on this object you'll have your
state which is your initial state and
your getters mutations actions which are
all the functions used to
interact with your store and then if you
want to modularize your store maybe your
swords growing you have a lot of
different parts of the store you can
separate them as modules and just create
kind of all these sub view stores which
is really easy to use concept and I love
the design of it and also external
plugins are very easy you just import
the plug-in and you put it in the
plugins array and it works and then
you'll just under your view instance
you'll just import this the same way and
say store that I want to use this as
store on the view instance which is
super easy this is how you set the
initial state so you can anything that's
valid object syntax and JavaScript will
be valid on the initial state and if you
want to interact with your store on your
components there's no additional setup
needed all you have to do is access this
dollar signs store and you can access
your state your getters mutations
basically any any thing you put on your
store any function or a bit of data you
can access through this and it also
gives you a few other helper methods to
be able to access this but this is the
most basic way to interact with your
store view CLI so this is I think the
biggest part of JavaScript fatigue is
setting up applications and I've had
this headache working in react for a
long time and end with lots of other
things I think it was mostly webpack and
this tooling has been a major
frustration for a lot of people it's
basically a nightmare if you have to
spend days or a week setting up your app
and you have to set up your dev in your
pod environment and then there's the
linting and transpiling and there's so
many other things going on in the
JavaScript world and it's just so
frustrating this is a famous tweet just
an example that
it just took so much effort just to get
the hello world ready
of course reactives tried to mitigate
this creating the create react app which
took quite a while to come out but I
guess it works much better now but I
think view made some very good design
decisions and making it very easy and
simple to just start using it so they
have something called view CLI version 3
actually came out recently earlier this
year and all you have to do is globally
install mu CLI and then vcli create my
project and it takes you through this
kind of easy step-by-step with creating
your project you can pick just a default
build and it'll do everything for you or
you can manually select features which
is probably what you're going to be
doing and from there these are probably
the most common things that are the
biggest pain to set up like CSS
pre-processing your state management
routing type script all these other
things even your testing and will
automatically set up for you it asks you
a few more questions based off of what
you choose like you can choose mocha or
jest or a few things like that and then
you also have the option to save that as
a preset for the future so then you can
initialize future projects if you're
prototyping a lot it might be really
useful
and one more thing that they did was
create a GUI
where maybe you're not familiar with the
terminal or especially newer people or
designers coming into the development
world are a lot less familiar with the
terminal so they wanted it to be usable
for everybody so I thought this was a
really awesome thing that I would have
never thought of it's a friendly UI
which does the same thing if you type in
view UI in your terminal then it pops up
with this GUI and it does the same thing
that the terminal does you can pick
where you want to store your project
what you want to name it and then it
gives you all of the same options that
you had in the CLI so do you want type
scripts support and all these other
things and then it will just set up the
project for you and then I think I'm not
sure but they might have functionality
to run it from the GUI now I'm not sure
if that's in there yet so view also has
official dev tools for Firefox and
Chrome and people also say they use it
in Safari but I'm not sure how that
works I don't think that's officially
supported and the view dev tools is
super easy because the naming is very
good and I think the layout and just the
UX of the whole thing is very nice and
this is where part of the importance of
having the routing as a main package as
just a standard package comes into play
because it works very well with things
like the dev tools it has a lot of
built-in functionality where you can not
just look at your data and kind of
navigate around it but you can there's a
lot of functionality around using view
router and also there's a tab built into
the official dev tools for view X which
gives you a lot of very easy to use
options of course you can do standard
things that you could do with the redux
tools but I think it's just easier to
you
you can record things you can one cool
feature is that you can export your
entire state object and then for testing
you can import it later to use which is
really nice and then it has all of the
different scrubbing and going back and
forth in state and all of those standard
features the community is one of the
main reasons I think view is becoming so
popular now so they've gone really out
of their way to make it a very welcoming
place for everybody and they have a lot
of different tools to get to know view
and to interact with the community as
well the forum is quite active they have
a place where you can post new projects
that you built in view and get feedback
they have a very active chat room on
discord chat if you haven't used discord
it has a beautiful UI for chat and a lot
of developer and I guess gaming
communities are on there too and I just
want to point out there's links to all
the meetups and github projects and
everything there's a view meetup in
Sydney actually I'm assuming most of you
are somewhat local and it's quite active
I was surprised it has about 60 to 100
people going to their monthly meetups
which is a lot more than where I'm from
which is awesome so definitely check
that out they'll have a meet-up in the
next month or so they hadn't scheduled
it yet
and this was just the show until I
mentioned earlier so you can post your
projects that you build in view and get
feedback from very nice people and of
course just as a standard in the
front-end world there's a lot of
activity on code pen around view so you
can see a lot of what people are
building get examples of different parts
of an application maybe you want to know
how to build some type of form or
implement loading or something like that
there's thousands of projects about view
on code pen now and oh yeah jsfiddle
gives you a boilerplate starter for view
so if you go to jsfiddle dotnet make
sure you don't type in calm and jsfiddle
dotnet will give you just a standard
starting place with a to-do application
if you wanted to play around with view
which is nice if you want more kind of
more to the application of file
structure there's another online tool so
this is code sandbox io and they also
have online sandboxes for other things I
know they have react I'm not sure what
else they have but they have a starter
View app which gives you all of your
files and folder structure as well
so then you can start building out
components and really see how a view
application would work similar to how it
would be if you were to start an
application with the CLI
and I thought this was a really
interesting community community site few
jobs you can see job postings from
around the world I want to point out
that view is of course has less job
opportunities than other frameworks
right now but it's growing more rapidly
than any other framework so I think that
will change in the next year or two but
there are quite a few new postings on
here and on other sites that I saw and
even locally where I live in the US
there's quite a bit of activity and buzz
around view everyone wants to try it out
so why is view great for companies of
course you know it developers are
expensive they're sometimes hard to find
they there's a lot of onboarding and
training costs and then there's the
maintainability of the code which is
also costly so all of these things play
into why view is great if you've read
the read the book clean code which I
think a lot of developers have Uncle Bob
Martin mentions that the ratio of time
reading code versus writing is well over
ten to one and he goes on to argue it's
closer to a hundred or a thousand to one
and so it's very important when you're
choosing your tooling is it going to be
something that's easy to onboard new
developers and two for them to make it a
maintainable code base where many
different people are going to be jumping
in and out of these are some of the
stats for the cost of developers these
are in u.s. dollars so it's a little bit
more in Australia or less I'm not sure
but it's about forty thousand dollars to
hire an onboard a developer including HR
costs and things if you paying them a
90k salary plus benefits in twenty two
thousand for three months of training
that's very expensive and then if
developers aren't happy they'll just on
average leave in a year or two so mmm I
think the companies
should consider developer experience a
lot more than they do and I think by
using view which I'll show some of the
charts of the have how developers like
view later but it gives you a larger
pool of applicants to choose from as
well because it's easier for people to
get started with it and they can more
easily jump into it and since according
to the Stack Overflow and every other
and not every other but other surveys
about development developers heavily
skew young and inexperienced so that's
one thing to consider when you're
choosing a technology as well is will
young and inexperienced people be able
to understand and grasp this it's not
just for the person who has 10 years of
experience so this is just some charts
about what developers and companies
think about view unfortunately a lot of
the stats for view came out they're well
they're from 2016 or 2017
because we haven't finished 2018 yet so
they're not quite there but you can see
the fourth one from my left is view
jeaious with the largest yellow dark
yellow block and that is basically
people who would love to try view j/s
there's also some people who haven't
heard of UJS but it's way down from 2016
the previous year and view jeaious when
you look at the numbers has the highest
ratio of people who have tried it and
would use it again react is similar but
other than reactant view there isn't
another framework that has a good ratio
of people who tried it and would like to
use it again and then another problem
that some people have with view they say
well view is not backed by a large
company so I shouldn't use it but as
this cartoon kind of funnily says
it doesn't really matter there's been
lots of projects that come and go backed
by large companies and that's not a very
good indication of how successful a
project will be if it's just made by
Google or Facebook you have to look into
a lot more things I think on top of that
view is heavily endorsed by some major
companies especially in China a venue is
Chinese so I think he's very
well-connected in the China community
and so Alibaba and some other companies
started picking up view early on and
it's just kind of moving to the West
right now 2017 we saw a huge explosion
of view in westernized countries so some
signs that you're choosing a good
framework is that it's at least a few
years old so you can kind of tell you
know how it's going to go have there
been consistent improvements in the
framework is there a good communication
between the core team and the users and
the community as a whole and are there
lots of good projects and tooling being
consistently built and maintained around
it some not so good signs of course if
innovation slows it's they make a new
version that's maybe not backwards
compatible with the old version
everything breaks they don't communicate
it very well or if the docs are hard to
read and there's a high learning curve I
think that's a very bad sign of
adoptability of a framework here are
some kind of comical charts to kind of
illustrate if you should use a framework
so this is basically there's always
going to be an initial learning curve
just for any tool or framework and then
it becomes stable and then after a few
years there are no changes no updates
you know and then it just bombs and dies
out and everybody abandons the project
because there were no new updates I
think that's why it's important to wait
a few years and see if this constant
innovation then there's also a major
framework that kind of did
there's a huge initial learning curve
and then they come out with version two
and it's completely different and
everything breaks it's not backwards
compatible at all and they didn't
communicate things very well so a lot of
people just jump ship or started not
really having faith in the project
anymore maybe they're just gonna break
things every time so a very bad sign
with the framework so this is more of a
good sign you have your initial learning
curve which isn't too steep and then
with every new major version you'll have
a new small learning curve but no major
breaking API changes nothing that makes
it look like an entirely new framework
and yeah and developers are happy so I
think view has been following this
pattern
there's the API is pretty much similar
with good improvements every single time
and so this next chart I made a long
time ago which is a bit exaggerated but
I think it's still a good indication of
what framework to choose mm-hmm so I
think ease of use and continued
innovation are two of the most important
metrics and this is why jQuery was
adopted so quickly because it made all
these hard things like HTTP calls and
kind of navigating around the Dom so
simple and easy just dead simple to use
and view does the exact same thing for s
pas so I think if you haven't tried it
you should at least give it a try and
see if it makes sense for your team or
project
so some stats on view adoption now
of course github stars are not the best
metric but you can see it's comparable
with react and activity on github when
you look at watch stars Forks all of
those things issues issues are closed a
little bit faster than any other
framework I think which is good and
there's a lot of activity on the issues
and these numbers become a lot more
impressive when you put them in
perspective to the state of view a few
years ago so the number of github stars
in 2016 was seven point six thousand
2017 it was thirty seven thousand and
twenty eighteen as of a few days ago one
hundred and fourteen thousand so it's
just growing by orders of magnitude in
popularity now and I think over the last
year it's been the most starred project
on github or at least the most our
JavaScript project for NPM downloads you
can see a similar trajectory only it's
even steeper well under a million in
2016 these are total downloads 1.78
million 2017 and now just to date in
2018 it's already at 13 million and also
for dev tools now this was an
interesting metric that I haven't seen
really used before to denote how many
active users a project has but Evan you
shared this earlier this year at this
his state of view address he gives every
year and I thought I think this is a
really good indication of how people are
actually using the project so this is
through April or May there were three
hundred fifty five thousand over three
hundred fifty five thousand active users
compared to a four thousand last year so
it's also growing in popularity with a
lot of active projects and for 2016
through part of 2017 view aside from pre
which is a little red dot up there view
is was the most I guess grew the most
out of any different JavaScript
framework and I think it's by now it's
been over a year since then so I think
it's in the second or third block to the
right and it will probably overtake
angular and jQuery pretty soon I don't
see it overtaking react soon and that's
just because react is in so many
different verticals people are using it
more and more in VR and people have been
using it in IOT and then there's react
desktop and react Mobile react native is
quite popular which also uses the react
standard library now view did come out
with native script view came out with
1.0 earlier this year and it looks like
a really good implementation and they
also have desktop implementations but
all of those things are still a lot more
immature than the react ecosystem so
we'll see where things go I think that's
important to point out because a lot of
people choose react because they can
also build with react native but I think
view or a view native script is a very
promising tool native script has been
out for a long time and they've done
quite a good job of giving you a hundred
percent mobile API coverage just from
your Java Script and they also claim
that we I've used react native quite
extensively and if you're doing more
complicated things you do have to use
Swift or some underlying Java and kind
of embed native code inside your
JavaScript so the claim of native script
is that you'll have to be doing you'll
be doing that a lot less but I haven't
tried out that claim yet mm-hmm and I'm
gonna wrap it up with one of my favorite
quotes by Sarah Dresner about view which
seems to describe the view community
very well the view is just a lot of fun
it feels like a breath of fresh air and
all this mess of JavaScript land and it
makes a lot of difficult things easier
I have some I'm gonna tweet out all the
slides later gwen underscore faraday and
i have a list of resources here people
different ways to get started to view
the view sandbox and starter some
podcasts you should check out they do
their official news in a podcast form
and in a text form and then there here's
a good link to a framework comparison
basically it's a build of a to-do app in
every different framework or almost all
of them so it has you know react angular
react all of those different frameworks
and there's a good example of how view
kind of compares line by line of code to
all the other frameworks there here are
some good related view projects so i'm
actually building a blockchain solution
right now in view desktop view doh
there's also server-side rendering which
is a really good project that's quite
advanced in view and like I said before
native script to you and there's also an
initial implementation of view VR but I
don't know anyone has used it yeah I
think it's still experimental so yeah
this is me if you want to reach out to
me contact me for any reason or give me
feedback yeah just let me know so thanks
for coming if you want to come up and
ask questions you can do so individually
I guess thank you
[Applause]